Let me pick up on our caller from the five
three zero area code calling today from 5:00
right here on.
Five three zero.
Are you there?
Yes, I'm here, hello, David.
Yes, how are you?
Oh, I'm doing well.
I was just just called in.
I was wondering what you thought about third
parties affecting the election.
This time I voted third party last time.
And obviously that is all very well.
And, man, your connection is not sounding
great.
Am I the one with the bad connection today?
Very bad.
I can hear everybody excellent.
And you sound like you're talking through
a tin can.
Let me I'm actually calling from a nuclear
submarine.
Is this any better?
Yes, actually, a little bit.
You know, at the end of the hallway.
But it sounds good.
Well, I actually am in a hallway, so that
makes sense.
Listen, third party.
OK.
So I'm I don't believe that the two party
system best serves our interests.
I think that, you know, the Republican and
Democratic Party represent really a quite
a narrow scope of the political spectrum.
We would be better served with a much wider
scope of representation.
I also believe that for as long as we have
the campaign finance system we have and the
first past the post voting system that we
have, it's going to be extraordinarily difficult
for third parties to really make headway.
And in the short term, they will potentially
have the spoiler effect that it sounds like
you might be referring to from 2016.
Yep, totally.
I'm calling from northern California.
Sorry, I didn't mention that.
That's OK.
OK.
All right, well, I hope I answered the question.
I appreciate the phone call.
I do think we are finally getting the phones
are working properly, which is exciting.
Let's go to our next caller from the nine,
seven, eight area code.
Who's calling today from nine, seven, eight?
And where are you calling from?
Hi, my name is Isaac.
I'm calling from Massachusetts.
This is just a phone number from Alabam, I
believe.
Love it.
Okay.
I thought nine, seven, eight was Massachusetts,
but go ahead.
Oh, I'll get my bad.
So, yeah, here's my question.
How do you feel about the current Black Lives
Matter movement?
And do you think it will lead to meaningful
change?
And how do you feel about how the movement
currently doesn't have, like a current leader,
like a face to lead the movement?
Well, listen, I don't think it's my place
to say whether the movement should or shouldn't
have a face or a leader.
That's really up.
I don't even know to who because there's no
leader.
But I feel like it's up to someone else to
decide.
I consider myself Black Lives Matter adjacent.
In so far as many of the goals of Black Lives
Matter are the same goals that I've been pushing
for on this program for a very long time.
My my qualms with Black Lives Matter as a
pseudo organization are on the record that
none of them, I think, will come as a surprise
to people since I've talked about them before.
I believe that there was at the time when
the Black Lives Matter and Women's March were
sort of overlapping.
I think they went in the wrong direction from
the standpoint of having anti Semitic associated
people speaking for them and organizing events.
I think that the way in which some Black Lives
Matter chapters have thrown in with the anti
Israeli movement is self-defeating.
And it's only going to alienate what is really
a natural natural ally, which is liberal American
Jews.
I think that they are going to be alienated
by some of the anti Israeli language and stuff
about, you know, the fight for Palestine is
the same thing that that Blakley that, you
know, we're fighting for here against police
brutality, cetera.
You're starting to see really wacky stuff
come out.
Like the reason police are a problem in the
US is because they got training from Israeli
officials on trips and, you know, like really,
really crazy stuff.
So, you know, for me, I don't really get too
involved in the in the groups.
And I've not even talked about this for probably
more than a year.
But I'm glad you're bringing it up.
But I am Black Lives Matter adjacent in that
I support a lot of the ideas that I think
most of the people support that are part of
Black Lives Matter.
Great.
Yeah.
I believe, like the entire sentiment is very
like I feel like the public broadly approves
of what the spirit and sentiment is for Black
Lives Matter.
Yes.
But like, I feel like an immediate people
are portraying them as, you know, X, Y and
Z.
And I feel like that might like ruin the reputation
of the movement.
I was just hoping that we could just move
forward and talk about what really matters
about this moment.
Well, the thing is, what really matters to
you or to me might be different than what
matters, you know, to the people who are using
Black Lives Matter to push Israeli BTX versus
the people who are using black lives matter
to say, you know that what?
You know what?
Whatever.
I think the whole point is there are things
that will have widespread agreement and then
there are areas where you start to lose people.
And I would focus on the lowest hanging fruit
that can achieve the most meaningful change
with the biggest consensus.
OK, great.
Thank you so much for your comments.
Glad to be on your show.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.